foreign
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I am in San Francisco
with environmentalist conservationist
pro-nuclear activist author of the books
apocalypse never why environment
environmental alarmism hurts us all and
San Francisco why progressives ruined
cities Michael schellenberger thanks for
having me Michael it's a great pleasure
to have the opportunity to speak thank
you for taking the time um so you're a
lifelong Democrat here in the U.S even
running as Democrat candidate in the
2018 California gubernatorial elections
before leaving the party and running
again this year in 2022 as an
independent yes how was that it was a
blast yeah had a great time
yeah it was um you know it was very
short as three months
but it wasn't the thing that you fear is
that you've spent all your time raising
money and didn't have to do that
if I had succeeded and made it into the
runoff that I probably would have had to
do more of it but we had a great time
and we were able to elevate this issue
that we can we're so concerned about
which is the large number of mentally
ill and addicted people living on the
streets
but also the broader the broader
challenges facing California including
on energy issues so it was great to be
able to raise those issues we were
disappointed that we didn't make it into
the runoff but it was overall a positive
experience do you think you brought
those issues to the full and uh so that
they're now spoken about differently
than they were before yeah for sure I
mean the book San Francisco had an
impact as well just on the overall
conversation around the media but I
think running on that issue it would
just allowed more opportunities to kind
of get the message out and to challenge
particular ideas that people have
so for sure it did and then you know one
of the most positive things is that the
governor announced in the middle of the
campaign that he was going to keep our
last nuclear plant operating which was
really important for keeping the lights
on in California and it's a plant that
we've been trying to save for six years
wow
um so I would love to get into your two
books apocalypse never on San Francisco
in fact this morning I was at a coffee
shop around the corner and got stopped
twice because I was cut in that book
it's a popular book it turns out which
one uh San Francisco needs yeah in San
Francisco you were stopped in San
Francisco I can't tell you how happy
that makes me yeah and I got some good
feedback there I would love to get into
that but before we do uh I wanted your
expert advice
um because back in Europe just stop oil
and various other climate activists are
destroying great pieces of art so uh up
firstly just stop oil through soup over
Van Gogh some flowers at the National
Gallery in London in Potsdam Germany
climate activists of Leicester
generation through mashed potato over
Monet's lemon in Rome activists for
ultimate generation through pea soup
over Van Gogh's the sour in Madrid
activists taped themselves to the frames
of two works by Goya and graffiti of
plus 1.5 degrees Celsius on the wall in
between on top of that just stop oil
have blockaded the M25 around London
causing a lorry crash so I wondered if
you might help me with Joseph Boyle I've
got their uh
that sort of uh
their ethos their their their Ambitions
here and I wondered if you could tell me
where they're going right and where
they're going wrong so they asked they
demand that the UK government makes a
statement that it will immediately halt
all future licensing and consents for
the exploration development and
production of fossil fuels in the UK
because it's the very first step to
ensuring our survival our I'm assuming
they mean the human race rather than
just stop oil we already have more oil
and gas than we can afford to burn they
say let's get on with ending our
alliance on fossil fuels completely by
powering ahead with Renewables and
cutting energy Demand by insulating
Britain and rethinking how we travel and
by ensuring that no one is Left Behind
and everyone's voice is heard so are you
a fan of just stop oil as an
environmentalist
I'm not a fan let me I'm trying I was
trying to think of uh what do they get
right yeah uh what they get right is
that eventually we will move away from
fossil fuels I'm confident of that they
were right that they did not destroy
those works of art happily The Works
were mostly covered in Plexiglas as you
know from having visited them as I have
but there was more serious things that
occurred people have died in these car
accidents on the highways that they've
blocked that's very serious they are
disrespecting beautiful works of art for
no reason that has nothing they should
not be disrespecting these works of art
they're depriving the people that could
be seeing these works of art the chance
to see them and they're accusing the
people who enjoy these works of art of
somehow putting their own love of
beautiful works of art above the planet
and that's absurd you can love these Van
Gogh paintings the goyas the the Vermeer
without uh without it saying anything
about your relationship with the planet
so it's
nihilistic in the sense that it's sort
of destructive for the point of being
destructive
and it is also
um I think on um unduly alarmist uh
British carbon emissions have been going
down for decades they're at their lowest
level in over 100 years the main reason
for that is the transition from coal to
natural gas and nuclear
well they're opposing natural gas and
most of them oppose nuclear and
something I know from past work so the
main way that we will reduce emissions
going forward is the same way that we've
been doing it which is more natural gas
more nuclear power Renewables are very
limited for reasons that most people are
aware of they don't produce power when
the sun's not shining the wind's not
blowing they must be backed up by
natural gas in order to be integrated
onto electrical grids and Britain in
particular but certainly all of Europe
and to a large extent the whole planet
is in the midst of a terrible energy
crisis there isn't enough natural gas
and the consequence of there not been
enough natural gas the immediate cause
of course is is Putin's invasion of
Ukraine but this had been going on for
years we weren't producing enough
natural gas and the consequence is that
they're burning more wood more coal and
even in some countries like Poland
they're burning plastic waste to stay
warm so the alternatives to natural gas
are much worse than natural gas so those
are the things that they get wrong I do
think that they're in the grip of a bad
idea I think there's some lost
individuals who are acting out things in
their own lives that they'd rather not
deal with and I think it's run by
somebody who's demonstrated sociopathic
or even Psychopathic Tendencies meaning
the leader of that organization has put
uh his own desire for power above the
above the lives of the people that he
works with and of the people who use the
highways that have been hurt by these by
these protests what do you mean by the
power the power he's seeking power how
so yeah this is Roger halami's
co-founder of Extinction Rebellion
um he's power hungry I think he's power
mad
um there's narcissism there too meaning
a sort of empty desire for attention uh
which is there on the part of the
activist but he wants control he wants
power it's unreasonable what he wants I
think you see in him and in that
movement
very dark tendencies that we've seen in
other
you know in other destructive political
movements begin with the aftermath of
the French Revolution all the way
through the late 60s yeah you talk about
this in in Apocalypse never this sort of
religious aspect to environmentalism and
and the alarmism around that what what
do you think that is at its core if you
went deeper into that what is it a
frustration that the world how is it
that environmentalism has become a
religion do you think well these are the
two issues I think are the really
important questions which is if you have
so many environmental Trends going in
the right direction why do people think
the world is coming to an end if the
main solutions to climate change are
natural gas and nuclear why do the
people who think the world is coming to
an end opposing those two technologies
and I get to at bottom a psychological
need that I think is not being fulfilled
as people stop believing in traditional
religion so as you move away you know
all religions serve a psychological and
a sociological benefits the
psychological benefits is that it gives
life purpose and meaning if you follow
these rules you'll get into heaven or
you'll be reincarnated at some higher
level there's some sort of sense in
which my behavior matters for reasons
beyond my own life I have a Transcendent
moral purpose
when that goes away it's anxiety
provoking at the same time you have with
industrial capitalism just a huge number
of choices my grandfather for example
who was a farmer in Indiana it was a
devout Christian
he just didn't have very many choices he
knew he was going to grow up and be a
farmer he knew he had to follow the ten
commandments if he followed the Ten
Commandments he can get into heaven it's
much simpler life than the life that
I've had that we have that our kids have
where you have to decide what's my sex
you know where do I want to live what do
I want to do for a career who should I
want to be in a relationship with it's
anxiety provoking people are looking for
rules they're looking for some guidance
and people who struggle the most with
that end up gravitating towards you know
what what are basically Cults what are
basically really dogmatic and fanatical
religions of which apocalyptic
environmentalism is one we also saw a
kind of apocalyptic race politics around
black lives matter where you basically
have these beautiful sounding ideas
Greenpeace black lives matter uh LGBT
rights they get hijacked by people that
have much darker motivations motivations
for power and for attention that end up
being quite destructive well you you I
think also talk about the malfusion
aspect to it and and uh the the problem
of the religious analogy is that
religion you would at least hope most
religions have a positive aspiration or
look upwards there's there's an
antenatalist an anti-human aspect as
well to environmentalism tied into it so
it's not so positive I think
there was uh there you know you have to
so of course when we look back at
environmentalism there was a very
utopian positive component of it uh we
actually had a book in the United States
called ecotopia that was sort of about
it was a fantasy it was a novel about a
whole new world that existed it was
powered by Renewables that was still
there with people like Michael
um
Michael Paulin and you get in the kind
of gardening movement in the United
States also very strong in Britain you
get a kind of Renewables harmonizing us
with the Earth you have that that's
there but I noticed for sure over the
last 10 years and I think social media
is part of it an increasing Darkness to
apocalyptic environmentalism without
that Redemptive quality I think some of
it is that it just travels easier on
social media negative emotions just
travel a lot easier than the utopianism
I think it also had to do with an
apocalyptic sense after Trump was
elected after brexit occurred this
reversion towards nationalism and
national identity in a variety of
countries I think has created a darker
mood among liberal more left-minded
people and I think all those things fed
to this really catastrophist view of
human beings and what do you think the
solution to that is something very
positive I think it's it has to it has
to be heartfelt it has to be smart it
has to have courage it has to have all
those
I think the first thing is it starts
with some gratitude towards what's
occurred you know uh average human
lifespan was 30 years of age 225 years
ago when the Industrial Revolution began
now I think most of us can expect to be
80 if we died at 80 we'd be disappointed
you know we'd be why can we make it to a
hundred
our Ambitions are so much higher we've
achieved so much our freedoms are
incredible we have this incredible
prosperity and environmental Trends
actually turn out to be going in the
direction that we want them to be going
carbon emissions have been going down
basically in every rich country we have
we we do have abundant natural gas in
the world we're not shipping it we're
not producing it providing it to our
allies in Europe and Japan and Asia that
we ought to be doing we have this
incredible technology called nuclear
power that allows us to use a tiny
amount of nature to produce a lot of
energy and that means you can have fresh
water you can have fertilizer you have
abundant food so there's so much
possibility and hope there was this old
idea this enlightenment idea that we
would use all of our wealth and
Technology to lift everybody out of
poverty that everybody would get to live
free lives that the two billion 3
billion people that still have to use
wood and dung as their primary energy
would no longer have to girls could go
to school boys would not have to work on
the farm you know people that wanted to
work on the farm would still be be able
to but most people don't need to do that
so for me that's what gets me excited
that's a world of abundance it's a world
of prosperity of freedom
and I think it's more appealing to more
people than the darker Vision but I I do
think that the darker vision is meeting
certain needs that this Enlightenment
Vision hasn't been able to meet you say
an apocalypse never a paraphrase it's
something like that you don't think
environmentalists who don't talk about
nuclear power are sincere in their
environmentalism and you will then go
into the history of why we are
intrinsically anti-nuclear and I was and
you've dispelled some of my assumptions
on on the matter but why why is nuclear
power not more popular
well nuclear is so radical I mean it's
such a radical technology so it's first
and foremost radical in what it does to
the relationship between countries small
country can get a nuclear weapon and
never be invaded I mean that's basically
the guarantee of it so it's it's
nerve-wracking
weapons from from North Korea nuclear
weapons can hit where we're sitting
right now in San Francisco it's a
terrifying idea nobody likes it
so we can't do anything about it so
there's another reason for some of the
anxiety of the Modern Age
um but you make a point that there's a
there's a we some for some reason
generally speaking associate nuclear
reactors with nuclear bombs right when
they're nothing like each other a
nuclear actor is nowhere near as
dangerous and even close to being as
dangerous than nuclear bomb but we don't
make that distinction so easily that's
right I mean um even the weapons that we
use are basically you know we use uh the
manufacturing fertilizer is very similar
to manufacturing ammunition for weapons
and yet we don't worry about the
fertilizer
um causing Wars but I do think that the
association is powerful it has an
independent effect on how we think about
nuclear power but the main attack on
nuclear was precisely by the people that
we were just talking about which is that
these are folks who don't want a world
of abundance they want to keep other
people down in a really important sense
not always honest about that because
that's a it's an ugly view it's it's
taboo View
but that is what's motivating that and
you can trace it as I've done in the
book over many decades this idea that we
don't want all these people lifted out
of poverty we don't want abundant energy
and so the criticism in that sense of
nuclear is the same one of abundant
natural gas it's a fear of a human
Planet it's a fear of human Mastery it's
a desire for control by some by some
pretty small people
um who sort of see other people's
success coming at a loss to them it's
not everybody that has that view I don't
even think it's most people but they
were then able to trick people's brains
into associating the power plants with
the weapons they then exaggerated the
accidents that have occurred Fukushima
Chernobyl Three Mile Island the
accidents actually show how nuclear how
safe nuclear is but people imagine that
it made it are symbols of how dangerous
it was the nuclear waste which is like
the main reason nuclear power plants
produce zero pollution Energy Zero air
and water pollution the nuclear waste is
the reason for that because all the
waste instead of being in the
environment is is contained that's
turned into a scary sounding thing and
so there was definitely a manipulation
going on it was coming from a bad place
and it preyed on particularly those
associations that people have with
weapons well you just mentioned
Chernobyl there and this was the the
part in my book where I put about half a
dozen exclamation marks because I'd
always assumed and actually there's one
particular factors that women in Western
Europe were there was about 100 to 200
000 abortions you say yeah because women
were made to believe that the radio
radiation from the explosion would
affect their their bodies and and uh
what so there is a myth about Chernobyl
that I've just assumed what what what's
the truth about Chernobyl well let's
start with the accident itself I I often
point out that it would be I mean it
sounds crazy but there's with all these
accents there's reasons for grad
attitude one of them is that this was an
accident where the melted uranium fuel
was literally outside the plant okay so
it's and it's becoming aerosolized so
it's going into the environment from the
I mean it's horrible it's the worst
thing you could imagine the winds are
picking it up and so it's traveling all
over the world radiation is this is this
one of the benefits of radiation is that
it's so easy to measure and track we can
track the amount of radiation in this
room right now we can track radiation in
the body like that's how we know much of
how the body works is by attaching
Tracer Isotopes to different bodily
pathways
so we can see this radiation go
everywhere but we see no increase of any
cancer other than thyroid cancer and
thyroid cancers nobody wants cancer but
if you had to get a cancer thyroid
cancer is not a bad one because it's so
easy to treat with a synthetic thyroid
substitute called thyroxine so when you
look at the reports and it was what blue
is what basically made me pro-nuclear
was reading the reports and interviewing
the best scientists
somewhere like 200 people total will die
from Chernobyl over an 80-year period so
that number includes the 50 or so
firefighters that put out the fire
and then another 150 people over time
it's such a shockingly low number when
you consider hundreds of people hundreds
of firefighters die during 9 11 attacks
on the buildings firefighters die it's
I'm not saying it's a good thing but you
know putting that firefighters in
context
and then we know that it had a very
small environmental impact much smaller
than people realize so yeah when you
realize that it's really like those
those these women these poor women that
got abortions it's more like
it's not to say that that the exposure
doesn't cause any harm but it's a
relative exposure it's like being around
people that smoke cigarettes it's you
know it's not great you wouldn't want to
like live in a home with a lot of
cigarette smoke if you're pregnant but
but a low level of that exposure once or
twice or over a period of smaller time
is no reason for people to expect to
have uh significant damage and in
comparison with the damage caused by
fossil fuel energy plants you argue in
the book that it's there's no comparison
actually World Health Organization says
somewhere around 6 million lives are
shortened again I use a careful language
here as opposed to saying killed because
it means you know lives could be
shortened by radiation too but the
difference with the radiation from a
nuclear accident is that there's so
little of it and it's so rare whereas
the fossil fuel and biomass and wood
dung burning in the home
there's so much of that that's how you
get to a number like six million
premature deaths okay so uh if we've
talked about natural gas as I mentioned
a couple of times now uh uh I I would
like to ask you because the UK are
trying to buy the richest our prime
minister is trying to buy 10 billion
cubic meters uh of of uh LNG from you
Americans yeah and uh everybody is
everybody's not the only one yeah and we
also uh our former prime minister uh Liz
truss uh lifted the ban on fracking we
had but Rishi has just put down
reimposed it and um I wondered if you
could make the environmentalist uh
argument for fracking sure yeah I mean
my basic view with all these fuels is
that there's a progression from solid
fuels to liquid fuels to gas fuels
that's a good progression you want to go
from using things that use a lot of
natural resource to very little so it's
really Uh Wood and dung are the worst
coal is a big Improvement both because
there's more energy there's higher
energy density
but also you're burning the coal outside
the home rather than inside the home
with wooden dong and then from coal to
natural gas right away carbon emissions
are cut in half but almost everything
else goes down by much more than that I
mean if you think about like something
like a heavy metal which exists like
mercury in Coal that goes to almost zero
when it's natural gas so it's just much
cleaner that's why we can burn it in our
in our kitchens you couldn't burn wood
or coal in your kitchen gets too smoky
so then you get to uranium produces no
air pollution no smoke and then
eventually I think and a lot of other
people think we'll get to hydrogen gas
as a carrier fuel so that's the right
direction
um gas definitely has impacts you're
drilling underground with fracking what
you're doing is your directional
drilling so you're going into these big
rock formations called shale
and then you're cracking it or we call
it you know using water to fracture it
or Frack it and then you pull the gas or
oil out of it
um significantly better process than
coal mining for example not as good as
uranium mining uranium mining you just
need a much smaller amount of uranium
because it's so much more energy dense
so that's the way I think of it I've
fought to keep nuclear plants open so we
don't have to use natural gas
but I will strongly believe in natural
gas as better than coal so sometimes
people say are you for natural gas and
I'm I'm for it when it's replacing coal
wood and dung I'm against it
will you talk about the the difference
between coal but just just for listeners
who might not be familiar why is coal
worse than fracking in in terms of the
damage it does to the environment yeah I
mean we basically got to a place with
coal you don't have to you can do
underground mining but we basically got
to a place and also in Germany where
you're just ripping whole uh tops of
Landscapes apart and you're just
grinding up you know they've had to I
think they took down a church in Germany
they've gone under forests you're taking
we call it mountaintop removal in the
United States so and it just like it
sounds you're just moving a lot more
Earth a lot more nature you're hammering
Rivers get clogged up with the sentiment
there's all sorts of coal ash that has
to get stored outside
so the difference is with oil and gas
you're just you're pulling the oil and
gas out of the earth and you're not
you're you are having some above ground
impact but nothing close to coal and
then of course wood is worse because
you're actually having to log entire
forests so every step of that way you're
going from wood to Coal to petroleum to
oil is environmental progress so this is
one of the things you you write about
very eloquently in your book but there's
some other rather controversial or
certainly some things that blew my
little mind
um in your book uh including that uh
that you were pro-fast fashion
yes um which uh I'm when I can afford it
I actually can't afford fast fashion
yeah what do you mean by that when I buy
when I buy when I buy fashion it's fast
I just don't buy a lot of clothes but
yeah but the you make the case that
actually it's a good thing fast fashion
is a good thing for a Humanity yeah
that's right so the so people will say
you know what environmental problems do
you worry the most about
um I believe climate change is real I do
think we should do something about it I
do worry about it but for me the two
biggest environmental problems by far
are Forest destruction and overfishing
we eat too many fish and they have
different solutions but on the forest
the biggest pressure on forests is from
small farmers who need land to farm
pushing up against the forest Frontier
and we see that particularly in
sub-Saharan Africa
um in the book I spent a lot of time in
the Congo and other parts of that region
talking about the conflict between small
farmers and elephants and gorillas and
other animal species that are endangered
Brazil is a slight slightly different
dynamic in the Amazon it's more big soy
Farmers putting pressure on for us but
you also have some of the small farmers
too what are your problem with the
forest because another one of the
controversial to me State arguments you
make is that the Amazon rainforest isn't
are not it's not the long lungs of the
world as well right so often told
because actually it the amount of oxygen
it produces but is kind of
self-contained and not a net contributor
to the environment so what do you mean
when you say uh that you're worried
about the default deforestation yeah
they're um well so let me let's unpack
Amazon for a minute my argument on the
Amazon is that the best farmland and
also the Farmland that takes the
pressure off the rain forest is actually
Savannah which is
um uh you know above and basically below
the rain forest and so you you would
rather use those Savannah areas than the
rainforest there's less biodiversity
they're better for farming and also I'm
arguing for concentrating agriculture
rather than fragmenting the forest which
is bad for animal species so I love
forests just in the semi I love those
vermeers and Van Gogh's they're
beautiful full they're home to
endangered species I think they're uh
they are an international treasure but
Brazilians also need to grow a lot of
food to feed themselves and to grow
economically and that's why they need
soy
um
so yeah I think there's there's alarmism
that's really quite colonialist and
Prejudiced and unaware that the United
States and Europe for example that we
logged our forests and now we're trying
to get the Brazilians to stop unfairly
but then there is an argument that all
said well we do want to protect those
forests but let's then Focus farming
somewhere else in Africa
in order to produce more food on less
land and this is true everywhere but
certainly in Africa what you need is to
have jobs in the city and the jobs in
the city the obvious place for jobs in
sub-Saharan Africa would be making
t-shirts making tennis shoes that's
where poor countries start so Ethiopia
when it starts manufacturing it started
fast fashion it started those little
factories in the city
those would then allow Farmers to buy
fertilizer and tractors produce more
food on less land to be able to provide
more food for people that are no longer
working on the farm but it also means
you needed less land and it took the
pressure off of the forests so that's
that's quite a steeple chase but
basically that's the argument for
factories and industrialization is that
it reduces the pressure on rainforests
does the waste cause by fast fashion not
concern you
not much in the sense that if you
consider it's cotton and wool and wool
are two of the biggest or synthetics I
mean synthetics are made from petroleum
byproducts
um cotton is grown and it's not great
cotton it requires a lot of water now we
know how to produce water as well
um certainly you can use nuclear plants
you can desalinate you can have
hydroelectric dams in general the
biggest use of the land by humans is to
make meat and so when you're asking
about
sheer like environmental impact on
landscapes for me it's reducing the
amount of land that you're using for
meat and we know how to do that this is
produ that's having more heads of cattle
or heads of Pig and Chicken on less land
and then in terms of growing crops like
cotton it's just technological
innovation better seeds better
fertilizer better irrigation so now for
another what another thing that blew my
mind was the case against renewable
energy that you make against solar
panels and against uh wind and and I
think I was pretty much persuaded by but
would you mind telling listeners the
environmentalist case against sure wind
turbines and solar panels you know I
should say it's not a
um it's not a spiritual case in the
sense that we have solar panels in my
backyard they're a great Niche
technology and so so and that's I think
what solar panels have always been meant
to be is as a niche technology the
problem is when you start to try to get
a lot of electricity from them so solar
requires somewhere between three and 600
times more land
to then to generate the same amount of
electricity from natural gas or a
nuclear plant that's because sunlight is
energy dilute a little bit of sunlight
can fall on my on on us and it feels
good A little bit of you stand next to a
nuclear uh reactor and you'll die that's
just an energy density issue so
paradoxically or maybe not paradoxically
you want heavy energy density in your
power plants
you know protected by machinery and by
good care because that means that you
don't have to use as much natural
environment that's why I sort of joke
the same thing that makes nuclear bombs
so dangerous is what makes it so good
for the environment which is that it's
just high energy density so the picture
here is basically a picture of wanting
to move from matter intensive fuels wood
and dung and coal to energy dense fuels
like uranium
sunlight is the fuel or the flow that is
powering those solar panels making the
solar panels requires huge amounts of
resource as well about 300 times more
waste coming from solar panels just the
used solar panels then the high level
nuclear waste so the picture of
Renewables and then and then there's the
unreliability of them that makes
electricity very expensive it means you
have to have a backup power plants
always ready to turn on when the sun's
not shining is not blowing
so Renewables end up being quite bad for
the environment and I think there's some
real questions now even about how much
carbon emissions they create how much
pollution they create in the
manufacturing of the the technology
itself the refining of the materials the
minerals I mean it's a shocking five to
ten times more materials so that's more
a mining and you know again agriculture
is the big devastating you know human
activity on landscape so if you can
shrink food that's great but you don't
want to increase the amount of mining
anything if you're looking at basically
the long-term trend is towards doing
more with less that's that's why we
haven't had bigger environmental impacts
despite having all these people so
anytime you're having to do less with
more you know you're having to use more
resource for Less energy you're going in
the wrong direction I think you even
make the case that more people have died
from wind just in the maintenance of
wind turbines than from let's say
nuclear but perhaps maybe I'm not sure
if we kept that in there or not I think
we may have taken out the wind the wind
comparisons be the wind deaths became
very difficult to attribute so we I'm
not sure if the deaths the wind deaths
made into the book or not but if if it
did it's
um it's the the bottom line is that the
deaths from nuclear just from nuclear
and wind were both so low that we just
didn't make a big deal of it and they
don't and and the let's say a solar
panel it doesn't last that long anyway
does it it's 20 30 is it yeah I mean
you're supposed to go 20 30 years but
they've been taking them down in 15
years because they they're able to
produce newer ones for so much cheaper
um uh that another thing that kind of
smashed my previous assumptions was uh
that bioplastics were worse than uh
fossil Plastics because bioplastics the
decomposition of bioplastic will cause
more pollution than fossil Plastics that
we put to landfills anyway yeah I mean
part of this is not surprising that most
people might remember that we used to
use elephant tusks Ivory to make piano
keys and Billiard balls so replacing
ivory with fossil fuel Plastics which is
a a byproduct of the petrochemical
industry
you know prevented us from having to at
least they still hunt elephants
particularly for the Chinese who wanted
the ivory although that's going away too
but also I discovered that the sea
turtle shells were being used for
jewelry for all sorts of exotic uh
products in the 19th century those got
replaced by petroleum based fuels but
then even yeah Corn based sugar-based
biofuels the worst is you know I'm sorry
bioplastics bioplastics and biofuels
have the same problems which is that
they require using a lot of land most
people now know that palm oil was being
was destroying rainforest in Southeast
Asia and hurting the habitat of
orangutans
but it's a similar Dynamic with all
bioplastics is that you have to grow
crops and those crops end up using more
land
creating more pollution and also having
a worse impact when they broke down the
picture that people had is that if you
use bioplastics then they'll break down
faster they'll compost faster and that
turned out not to be true because in
order to make these products you know if
you think your forks or your bioplastic
cups or whatever they have to make them
in such a way that they don't just
decompose so easily so turns out you
know we have a really good solution
which is that we have uh in the United
States we use landfills and in Europe
they mostly incinerate there were
problems with incineration decades ago
but they burn really hot now and so they
break up the dioxin molecules those are
great solutions for our waste uh we
should every time we try to recycle
Plastics that's when you end up getting
plastic waste in the rivers and in the
oceans yeah you've written about this a
bit and I'm not sure I fully understand
but I was discouraged by the amount of
effort I put into recycling over the
last 10 years dividing on my recycling
yeah and reading reading your your work
I I've got the impression very little of
that actually ends up being recycled and
it was a lot of work in vain am I wrong
no and at this point you know uh I don't
agree with Greenpeace on much but on
this issue it appears Greenpeace is
arriving where we've arrived which is
that Plastics are definitely not being
recycled like at least 90 or more are
not being recycled and the reason is is
that it's just not cost effective the
materials that you get out of recycling
it cost more than getting the raw
materials because the raw materials are
this fossil fuel byproduct from oil and
gas production
so yeah it turns out that the attempts
to recycle it what happens is the
recyclers end up shipping the plastic to
poor countries that don't have Waste
Disposal Systems and then it ends up
making its way into rivers and oceans so
we ended up creating this giant ocean
plastic waste Problem by trying to
recycle our plastic waste which is very
ironic as you might in several ways you
know the more you think about it so so
yeah it's best for them to go in the
garbage
um or you know or in the incinerator uh
I think there's been some debate on
Twitter in the last few weeks about this
I still think it's uh cost effective to
recycle your plastic your tin cans your
aluminum cans your glass there's some
people who disagree around some things
like the paper but generally those are
the things you should be able to recycle
it's just that plastic because of the
chemical nature of it the lightweight
part of it and the fact that that
there's you already have a byproduct to
make it just not worth recycling that's
why it ends up not going into it why it
ends up not being recycled okay I don't
fully understand what happens then with
the incineration and the landfill stuff
why why is that okay because are they
self-contained is there not leakage or
yeah
no the new landfills are sealed really
well they put these good sealants on
them we also uh pull the gases off and
we burn the gases as methane to provide
a little bit of electricity it's
certainly better than it going up into
the air because methane is a potent
greenhouse gas if it's not you know
broken apart through combustion which is
what those special you know land you
know basically waste to energy projects
do
um and yeah it's not it just doesn't
take up that much land I mean it seems
like we would be taking it like using up
all of the Earth for landfill space
because there were so many of us
producing garbage but it's just not a
problem and then we end up building
parks and golf courses over them Europe
doesn't have as much land that's why
Europe incinerates uh Japan incinerates
they have a big incinerator right there
middle of Tokyo or several probably and
they just burn really hot now and so you
do get a little bit of carbon dioxide
but nothing compared to energy
production and then you don't what's
important is that you don't get dioxin
which is a toxic pollutant and it's just
simply because it breaks apart the toxin
molecule because the heat is so high now
okay so as we're talking world leaders
right now are in Egypt for cop 27 the
United Nations climate change conference
does that fill you with hope that the
world leaders are meeting
No in fact there was like a few I've
been working on climate change for you
know almost a quarter Century that's how
long I've been working on it since my
mid-20s I'm 51 now so there was a period
there where I just didn't even talk
about it like people would ask like
reporters would be like would you
comment on the talks and be like no
because there's like no point they'd
have no impact
there's these are you know someone a New
York Times Reporter asked recently he's
like why don't they just do them by Zoom
they take you know it's like 30 000
people it's all this energy of course
every time they have them there's all
these stories about
all the private jets that fly and arrive
there in the hypocrisy of it um
but I kind of was joking you know why
why don't we do the Hajj over Zoom you
know why don't you have a pilgrimage you
know over zoom and the reason it's a
pilgrimage it's a religious event
it's not it shouldn't be understood as
an event that will decide how Nations
what how they use energy or how they use
food that's the conceit of the people
who attend those meetings but these are
people often who are activists they're
politicians these are people that don't
really understand how electrical grids
work or energy systems work they go
there and they're kind of in a
journalists are there they also don't
understand this the activists are there
they have very little to do with like
real world decision making so that's why
I kind of go it's just a festival of
narcissism there's no point in
even talking about it it's more
interesting at the cultural level you
know it's more interesting that it seems
like it's also enacting a fantasy of
rich countries controlling poor
countries so you'll see this the way it
works is that they'll be like we'll pay
you because we feel guilty for having
caused climate change that you know we
rich countries cause you didn't so we'll
pay you and you in in exchange will
agree not to use fossil fuels well a
country that decides not to use fossil
fuels ninety percent of them means
they're deciding not they're not going
to grow economically this ties back to
the earlier in the conversation that
they're going to get left behind yeah I
mean some of them can use hydroelectric
dams many poor countries start with
hydroelectric damage but they all need
petroleum to move trucks around and
transport farm products to the cities
and so the idea that you would get poor
countries not to use fossil fuels is
imperialistic it's the reverse of the
earlier imperialism the earlier
imperialism would build the highways so
you can pull the materials out of of the
country that kind of imperialism China
is still pursuing Russia is still
pursuing but now Europe and most much of
the rest of the of North America Asia
slightly different
has said no we want to pay you not to
develop and so you're going to stick
with Renewables and so you saw things
like Germany last year gave South uh
gave South Africa 800 million dollars to
agree not to burn coal well in the time
since that event that was the Scotland
climate talks last year same time as
this year since then Germany's Imports
of coal from South Africa increased
Eightfold so you're just it's not just
hypocrisy it's imperialist and it's
malthusian in that it's saying
you go ahead and Skip economic
development for our sins against nature
wow is there any sense that anyone a cop
27 or is any of the leaders getting the
conversation right is there anyone that
you you do think is understands the
problems as you understand them
well they actually many of them
understand it and they just end up kind
of going through they they end up they
end up reading from the script
um even politicians that know that they
have to go back to Germany or France and
find ways to go produce more oil and gas
I mean what you've been seeing over the
last several months even before Russia
invaded Ukraine in late February is
world leaders going to Canada going to
the United States going to Qatar going
to Australia and begging for more
natural gas that's the main event so
then you kind of go oh well forget all
that now we're gonna go to this kind of
conference and talk about how we're not
going to use fossil fuels is that is
that because their article to uh their
to democ democratic countries I the
people who are on mass misguided or if
is there something is there an elite
cabal of people with nefarious aims as
you suggested that really a little bit
there's some within a very same wanting
to keep some countries down what's what
why has it come to this point yeah I
mean the answer is yes of course on both
there's there's a there's a there's a
domestic constituency a third let's say
of the electorates in every developed
economy that feel that you should you
should prioritize climate change over
cheap energy over economic growth we see
that in the polls here we see in Europe
and so that and that that's a
disproportionate part of central left
parties Across the Western World so of
course they you know macron and and
rushi sunak is this is much more
left-leaning electorate in Britain
um but but Biden and German leaders I
mean they all go and they all say that
at the conference but then they go back
home and they also have to rush around
the world to get enough fossil fuel so
this is to buy
by conceptual like it's just doing two
things at once for them is there an
elite cabal well of course it's it meets
the Davos every every year it's called
the world economic Forum
um you know whenever you talk about it
people say oh it sounds like you're
talking about a conspiracy theory my
response is always I wish it were a
conspiracy because that would make it
quiet instead it's very loud the global
Elites are very loud about what they
want they talk about it all the time the
great reset was not something hidden it
was a very well publicized books about
it yeah they wrote books about it so and
it is what it is they just have been
saying the same thing for 50 years I
mean the great reset
gives it some more frisson you know it
gives it some more excitement but it's
Malthus it's malthusianism it's this
idea that we should all rely on
Renewables spoken by people that just
just arrived a few hours ago from Aspen
on my private jet you know so so yeah
it's all it is what it looks like does
that not then fill you a little bit with
despair if these are the people in
charge and they're so misguided on the
topic as as you understand it how can we
disrupt that if if they're so wrong
definitely there's times where my work
feels futile and I guess the best you
mean by despair you know it's also like
compared to what you know compared to
you know the wars between Catholics and
Protestants in Europe compared to the
great days of imperialism of European
imperialism compared to
you know uh the you know the inner War
period I mean it's just uh we're the you
know I'm just started I don't I realized
I didn't know anything about Napoleon so
I started reading this biography of
Napoleon and I'm like which one it uh I
can't it's the single it's a single
volume Andrew Roberts might be uh
putting the Great
yeah it's a single volume biography I'm
sorry I don't remember the the author
I'm never I'm terrible about that um but
it's like a nightmare from beginning to
end and he's a psychopath you know he's
like no there's no Roberts Roberts loves
him oh okay sorry yeah there's a lot of
people in Napoleon I think there's at
least a million remorselessly you know
and it's uh you know that was whatever
you know that was a you know late 18. so
kind of compared to what you know as far
as fantasies go there have been worse
ones there's been worse delusions I
would definitely worry about sub-Saharan
Africa I worry about South Asia these
are places that do need more energy
Pakistan just announced that it's going
to have you know gas you know mandatory
gas you know shortages and rationing
this winter because the Europeans have
bid the price of natural gas up so much
the pakistanis can't compete with them
so I worry about that it's not it's not
great I guess the war the warrior would
more be that if we really are in a
climate crisis which maybe you'd ask
against yeah then and the people in
charge of dealing with it are so Off the
Mark then we're not going to get
anywhere to closer to resolving that
issue well yeah I mean it's true you
know I will say this energy crisis has
been very good in terms of the decisions
it's inspired some of the leaders to
make uh you know there's a setback with
sunac I do think that Britain needs to
produce more of its own gas so it's not
so dependent on the rest of the world
including on us but France has decided
to go more nuclear plants Japan and
South Korea after being anti-nuclear
since Fukushima a decade ago is now are
now moving back towards nuclear I was
just in Korea and nuclear as mainstream
among liberals on Twitter nuclear is
remarkably mainstream much more
mainstream than when I started working
on this in Earnest 10 years ago so so
you see things and there's some of these
things I look at I go it's headed in the
right direction other things I go
there's a lot of crazy there still
um but definitely I do think that
countries are going to start to see the
need for more nuclear and gas
it's annoying how long it takes people
to get to the most you know obvious
conclusion in my view that those are the
two technologies that ought to be
emphasized but
but yeah so my despair is uh you know I
would say uh marked with some moments of
joy as well uh well my last question on
environmentalism before I want to move
on ask about your San Francisco book is
uh we both saw the Greta tunberg
Memorial outside
uh uh the um mural I should say
um uh matron saint of uh Eco anxiety
maybe you said it or are you a fan
well I'm very interesting Greta's very
interesting for a lot of different
reasons you know I think I've been
critical of her as you might imagine I'm
I'm interested in sort of why a
civilized society chooses a girl as its
hero and you're you know she had
authentic appeal she went viral on
social media she was certainly packaged
well by her handlers
but I think one of the obvious reasons
is that she could then be above
criticism and that's that's what part of
this movement wanted is it wanted to
make climate change and Renewables above
criticism it's really in there and I
know from personal experience it's very
taboo to suggest that climate change is
not the end of the world and that we're
actually adapting to it pretty well and
we're going to keep we've been reducing
emissions we're going to keep reducing
emissions
and that Renewables aren't going to be
the main event by any means and that
we're not going to return to a
pre-industrial world we're not going to
go back to Elizabeth in England by the
way I think as sort of the archetype
that even Americans have in their minds
you know the renaissance fair and the
music and we miss that you know there's
something
nostalgic and beautiful about that where
we made our own music you know where we
where we created we were creators in our
own communities we produced our own food
and energy and music and cultural life
and I think there's Nostalgia for that
with understandable reasons
but I think that's what the climate
discourse the apocalyptic discourse is
all wrapped up in
so they but what concerns me about Greta
you know she's obviously as she says she
had an anxiety disorder and was
depressed
she also suffered I believe she said
from OCD you can see some of that I see
in some of the OCD I see it a lot around
the concern around plastic waste it's
almost obsessive in the kind of you know
the Sorting you know OCD is often
manifested by by purifying and
separating things certainly being clean
but also you know segregating and
separating and recycling had a lot to do
with that but the people around her knew
she had an anxiety disorder you know
when she got up in front of the United
Nations she was you know throwing a
temper tantrum you know and saying
things that you don't have to be Sigmund
Freud to kind of be like that doesn't
sound you know saying things like how
dare you and you've stolen my childhood
well I mean who's she talking to there
is she really talking to United Nations
delegates is she talking to her parents
I mean what are we we're seeing a kind
of
psychodrama unfold publicly and anybody
who said something who said well I don't
think that's appropriate for a uh
frankly an upper middle class Swedish
girl to be acting like the world owes
her something that's entitlement that's
grandiosity that's a kind of narcissism
you know anybody who would say that then
was oh well you're picking on a girl or
something so it became very
um very much part of the woke phenomenon
too you know which was this idea that
you know when I first started working on
climate change you know you were you
were worried about victims in poor
countries mostly you were well people in
Africa are going to have a harder time
adapting that was the concern well now
in the segues to the you know the latest
protests it's I don't have a future
you're destroying my life this is about
me me me me me and I can't help but read
that as you know a sign of of a culture
of narcissism and the rising narcissism
that everyone has been talking about as
it relates to social media well and on a
recent sub stack uh piece you you even
more damning than that which was that
you you think that she's more driven by
hatred of capitalism than a love from
the environment well and she said so I
mean so this came out she gave us she's
got a book coming out in the spring she
gave a speech in Britain and she got up
and said you know this is not you know
just about climate change the is about
capitalism she was actually making a
great reset argument you know she was
saying we should not go back to normal
you know after covid so we don't want to
go back to normal life we want to go
back we want to tear down capitalism and
that's because capitalism
you know is slavery the destruction of
indigenous people and you know and I
pointed out in my I wrote two pieces on
the first piece I point out you know
what we call industrial capitalism
certainly has had some brutal parts of
it but it also you know liberated humans
from drudgery and you know like I
mentioned you know life expectancy from
30 to 70 years and women and girls are
not the property of their fathers and
husbands these are all things that might
you know you might want to take into
consideration when you're condemning
capitalism the other thing you might
want to consider is that we haven't had
a great track record with other forms of
economic organization the two big
competitors being feudalism and
capitalism which have a lot more in
common than people imagine they're both
involved in in trying to control
economic life you know we came to this
agreement out of Europe out of the
Protestant Catholic Wars it was Hobbes
and these other thinkers
in that period of you know 16th 15th I
guess 16th 17th centuries saying you
know humans are very aggressive and
greedy so why don't we let them do that
in this realm of the economy we'll call
it you know that'll be what Mark's
eventually called capitalism we're going
to let them have that in the economy and
then we're going to allow this other
space you know the public space the
government to protect people and provide
people with their needs but we're going
to actually allow these two very
different kinds of human activities to
exist side by side
hasn't been perfect but as far as I can
tell it's had much better outcomes than
the alternative so can I ask you about
San Francisco yeah I found it to be a
very empathetic book and
um amongst other things dealing with the
homelessness here in San Francisco and
one of the misdiagnosis probably and
again assumption that I'm partly I've
partly made myself is that people who
are homeless it's often because uh you
know they're I hard luck I've had a
tough time in their lives but actually
the real problem is uh
a crisis of
mental health and a crisis of addiction
and that those two are the real root
causes of of the the problem problem
which here you just you walk three yards
and you're faced of it it's it's really
shocking here more than anywhere in Los
Angeles as well it's similar
um
and you argue that
um uh Progressive policy as opposed to
conservative policy is making things
work is is that demonstrably true that
Progressive policy here in America let's
say is hurting the homeless more than
it's helping sure and I should say too
the people we call homeless they are
down on their luck but it's not a simple
that they're unemployed and so I point
out that you know people that often lose
their job or they can't afford the rent
in San Francisco they do what millions
of people in California have done which
is that they move they move out of state
they go to Texas that's what's been
happening here California's become a
wealthier state because we haven't built
enough housing to retain the working
class and the middle class so those
folks move when they can't afford they
don't go live on the most dangerous
sidewalks in the world these are folks
who are there overwhelmingly because of
addiction they need all their resource
they use all their resources to support
their drug habits many of them suffer
serious mental illness but it's even
those folks tend to have a serious
problem with substance use disorder so
it's a psychiatric disorder
that leads people to make really bad
decisions like you know living on the
streets
um you know the men engage in Theft to
maintain their habits and women engage
in sex work some of the men engage in
sex work it's terrible life and so we
now know from both cohort studies that
follow the sheltered homeless and the
unsheltered over time and we also know
by comparing Los Angeles to New York
because the Los Angeles has so many more
unsheltered homeless people that live
outside that living outside is an
Untouchable children homeless uh leads
you three times more likely to die than
if you're indoors and it's everything
from car accidents homicides drug
overdoses you're safer indoors so then
what's the difference between sheltered
and unsheltered sheltered unsheltered
geologists Outdoors yeah the people you
see on the sheltered is out of tent or
no sheltered as indoors at a proper
shelter so unsheltered would be a tent
and yeah three times more likely to die
that's right yeah and so so you have to
bring people inside
um the conditions can be bad inside we
should make shelter you know clean safe
you know it should be a proper shelter
we have a moral obligation for that we
have a legal obligation for that but
it's better than being outside I mean
outside is just dangerous
so that's kind of the argument then you
have to ask yourself why are we leaving
people outside you know what is going on
what is the justification for letting
people stay outside and that was part of
why why I wanted to write San Francisco
I mean part of it was to kind of lay out
look these aren't this is not just
people that can't afford the rent and
have our everything's fine other than
just being short a few bucks that was
the first part to point out that's not
true and then the other was sort of why
given you know and I look at places like
I mean I'm obsessed with the Netherlands
and a lot of different reasons but
when I am a practical person so when I
kind of go what works it's not actually
that I think Netherlands is conservative
I wouldn't even call their approach to
homelessness to addiction mental illness
homelessness as conservative I don't
think they consider themselves
conservative I think if anything they
would call themselves liberal and
compassionate but they've just done a
set of things and so part of me asked
why don't we just do the same things the
Dutch have done to take other people
what's getting in the way of it and what
have the Dutch done the Dutch I mean
have said everybody needs to come inside
I did Shadow a social worker where we he
let someone stay outside for the night
rather than making him come inside but
then the next night he said you to come
inside and I think if I hadn't been
there he might have made him go inside
that night
um you know and I say to him well you
know do you have a shelter bed for him
of course you know what if he needs a
bed and a psychiatric hospital or in the
psych ward of a hospital do you have
that for him yes you know what about
drug rehabilitation what if he needs
drug rehabilitation we have that so the
first thing is they have these
facilities and then the second is that
they they're Americans dead which we
don't which we don't
um we have some but we don't have enough
and then the other part of it is then
they have the legal power to get people
inside you know it's similar to what I
think we ought to do which is that I
don't think you should be made to go
into the shelter but you can't sleep
outside so you can try to stay with a
friend or family you can go out of state
you can whatever you don't have I mean
you you know but you can't be on the
sidewalk it's not safe for you it's not
safe for anybody else
so that is also those are the two big
changes it's basically you need the you
need the beds whether it's in a shelter
rehab or hospital and you also need the
legal authority to require people to get
off the street and it's that combination
of social help but also the legal and
you emphasize punishment a little bit
more in the book as I understood it
there needs to be incentive or strict uh
policing I suppose yeah I mean the way I
like to think of it is there need to be
consequences for behaviors that are
destructive that are self-destructive
destructive to the society if you don't
have consequences for those then you'll
have more of those behaviors you know
you are what you allow and so we allow
destructive behaviors in San Francisco
that are unhealthy and unpleasant and
dangerous
for ideological reasons certainly not
for lack of money because we're rich in
fact part of the the the spending of
money on things that encourage those
behaviors is why we have more of those
problems here but punishment's a funny
word i i i there nieta has a great
aphorism which is beware all those in
whom the will to punish is strong I've
never felt I don't feel a punishing uh
like like I don't have a any kind of
desire to punish people in that sense
but I do think when you don't have
consequences for doing the kinds of
activities it's the drug specifically
just to be not sleeping rough that you
understood you encouraging punishment
for but when there's drug dealing or
possession of drugs I suppose that's
wrong that there should be repercussions
for that yeah well possession is tricky
I think if you're I you know I always
say I'm a liberal in my compassion for
the vulnerable I'm a Libertarian in my
love of Freedom I'm a conservative and
that I think you need civilization to
protect both of them if you are using
drugs in the privacy of your own
apartment or hotel room I don't think
that that should be a priority for law
enforcement if you're using them outside
on the sidewalk if you're selling them
if you're defecating in public if you're
doing if you're breaking laws in public
then I think then and it's clear that
it's driven by addiction as evaluated by
a specialist or a counselor or a
therapist or somebody I've been advising
the judge and it seems to me the judge
is appropriate to say look you can go to
jail for your crimes or you can go into
rehab and what we've done in San
Francisco is we've taken away the stick
we've taken away the threat of jail and
said would you like rehab most addicts
say no I'm perfectly fine my life is
awesome right now I just need to smoke
some some Fentanyl over the next couple
hours and I'll be super good
those folks then don't get the care they
don't get the treatment they need
because they're having a psychiatric
disorder because the policy has been to
give money and shelter so that they have
the shelter and they have more money to
buy the drugs is that correct yeah it's
as shocking as it sounds I mean San
Francisco is a little unusual in this
than other Progressive cities but
basically yeah you get six to seven
hundred dollars in cash
if you claim poverty even if you're from
out of town
and then you can live on the street and
use your drugs and and be left alone for
the most part that's that's how you get
a lot of people on this so that's come
from a very empathetic Point that's like
if you if you think the problem is
homelessness that seems like a solution
but it's that's the misdiagnosis right
there
yeah and there's been efforts to tighten
it up you know there was a a policy that
said look you can I mean you can't have
the apartment and cash so you can get a
free apartment unit
but then you can't get the free cash so
then a lot of people will say well I'll
take the cash
and I don't want the apartment unit and
then there'd be people that would say
well why are we you know a lot of people
including doctors saying it's crazy to
give addicts cash like it's crazy but
the argument that it's cruel to not give
poor people cash basically one out over
the argument that it was cruel to give
them cash what do you think uh America
or this region is lacking in the mental
health care
well the main issue I think well there's
several issues the first is that if you
don't have any coercion if you don't
have any requirement that people will
accept the treatment as an alternative
to incarceration then people won't take
the treatment that's just something that
everybody knows around the world they
know that in Britain they know
Netherlands they know in Japan so that's
the first part you have to have
consequence but the other issue is
um we don't have the centralized kind of
care that exists in most developed
economies in Britain you have the
National Health Service in Canada they
have a single-payer system where it's
much easier to deliver that care in an
efficient way so for example if you need
drug treatment and you're arrested in
San Francisco it's too much to ask San
Francisco to be able to provide drug
treatment for every addict who comes
here twenty thousand homeless addicts
basically come to San Francisco every
year I don't know if they're all addicts
20 000 homeless people come into City
every year about 8 000 at any given time
passing through are they they move past
well yeah there's about eight thousand
to eight to ten thousand total homeless
in the city at any given time 20 000
that come through the year come to the
year so there's a significant amount of
turnover a lot of people die
a lot of people move out of town
um some people finally get housed some
people quit doing drugs but it's a
pretty significant churn San Francisco
can't provide care for everybody
um that comes true so there needs to be
I think care centralized at the state
level that is then also uh supported
financially by the rest of the country
because people come here from Texas and
Ohio and all sorts of part of the
country to maintain in part to maintain
their addictions well Michael Michael
schellenberger thank you so much for
your time I highly recommend your two
books to uh listeners I'm sure they'll
enjoy as much as I did them as much as I
did but it's been a great pleasure
speaking with you thank you thank you so
much for having me I appreciate it
foreign